you
came up in boston mm-hmm which is um
a dope city uh it's an interesting city
i've been there a lot so i know a lot
about boston
i mean i love it i love little italy
there especially what i ever had by the
way shout out to boston
but it's also like kind of perceived as
like a racist city kind of it is
is it a racist city it was perceived
that way it's perceived that way
yeah it's like that in some places
though because you know it's it's kind
of like
we just think of like drunk white irish
dudes out there
they have those you know you watch the
departed and [ __ ] and you're like
is everyone like whether there's townies
and they does everyone sound like bill
burr when they talk
no no they they do they sound
you know what i hate about people they
don't think that boston has like any
culture that massachusetts has like
any blacks or latinos like there's a lot
of culture out there
of course it's just in its own areas
like yeah i mean look i mean we're
talking about earlier i love you
i love lawrence lawrence is a dope area
yeah lawrence is all
puerto ricans and dominicans hey
terminology's from boston and he's
puerto rican
yeah i [ __ ] with him shout out to term
one of the most underrated dudes
he's a legend a legend for sure and then
there's like
let's give him his flowers while he's
right here let me tell you something
about terminology static selected 1982.
yup you know what i mean shout out to my
guys good dad gang go buy a [ __ ]
terminology
everybody from boston they're flowers
right now let's give the celtics their
flowers are we going to
give the bruins are we going to get
benjamin and cam newton has flowers yes
yes cause it's koi's dad and that's my
girl okay
everybody from boston gets their flowers
yeah coyla rae
shout out to coyla ray man she's doing
her thing yeah that's my girl i [ __ ]
with her
yeah she's i love her energy me too very
positive she's just having fun
you know what i'm saying i love it yeah
boston is yeah but you know there's
there's so many uh legendary cool people
from boston hell yeah static selected
one of the greatest hip-hop producers of
all time and my brother man i love that
guy man so